hello well I'd like to begin
by uh saying good evening to to all of
you I'd like to thank you uh Pedro
Sanchez our host for the uh uh excellent
organization both of the meeting that we
had yesterday the EPC as well as this
European council meeting very
important the Granada declaration uh has
been adopted and that is a very
important Point of Departure this is
going to allow us to continue the work
of the European Council in the weeks and
mon months to come so as to continue
identifying the Strategic agenda for the
EU and I'd like to thank uh the Spanish
presidency for the very active uh
participation in the work and thank you
very much for the resilient 2030 report
that was a very substantial input to the
political work that we are to be
done over the last few
years we have all
seen uh different crisis that have hit
the world Hit
Europe the climate change coid
19 and also the war of aggression uh by
Russia in Ukraine and that has had
negative repercussions from the economic
uh point of view and there is one thing
that we've all seen we need to work
relentlessly together to be less
dependent uh more autonomous take our
destiny in our hands and overcome the uh
challenges that we face as you know we
have made significant steps forward in
the enlargement of the EU strategic
decisions have been taken and we will be
talking about that more in the near
future and we need to focus on three
questions the framework for this
political to do together what are our
common priorities for the future what
are the common policies for the future
the second one how do we make sure that
we will act to together that we will
able to act together it refers to the
decision making process and the third
question is always extremely difficult
this is the financing the money how do
we make sure that we have a budget in
line with our common uh Ambitions and
today the leaders have had a real in
depth exchange of views this has the
occasion to listen to each other to
better understand what are the common
priorities what are also the differences
uh among the member states so that we
can identify ify what we need to do in
the weeks to come in the months to come
to decide on common orientations on
common uh
principles four points are extremely
important the first one we need to
strengthen our economic basis our
technological basis it is absolutely
clear that uh Green Tech artificial
intelligence quantum computer these are
challenges for all of us and it's
extremely important to identify what are
our ambitious uh what are Ambitions
strategies on those questions second
topic security and defense there is no
doubt that the war by Russia against
Ukraine has demonstrated the importance
to invest more in capabilities to
develop our industrial basis also
including with important role that must
be played by
thees Third Point Energy uh we have been
working a lot for more sovereignty for
more Independence and we need to
continue to maintain the efforts to
speed up and to maximize the efforts in
that field as well and finally my fourth
point we need to engage with the rest of
the world and this what we are doing but
we need to do more it's not by
coincidence that the European Council
took the decision to have more Summits
with third countries and you know that
two years ago more than two years ago we
had important Summit with the African
Union with had also Summits with asan
with Latin America and we intend to be
very active to engage with the rest of
the world because we think that what's
at stake this is a multipolar world we
believe in a multipolar world and we
believe the fact that for a multipolar
world the EU has a special
responsibility a special role to play
and that's why we are very active in
addressing uh the challenges together
with the so-called Global SCE together
with the prime minister of Spain a few
weeks ago in New York we took some
initiatives to try to mobilize the
International Community including the
global s to address the questions of
fairness at International level more
inclusivity which are important common
challenges finally one last word about
migration because we had also decision
today to discuss migration not the first
time not the last time you know that
since uh January this year each European
council meeting we had the occasion to
this the topic and to have a state on of
play especially on the external
dimension of migration point one we are
pleased and I am pleased that thanks to
the huge efforts including by you and by
your team Pedro the huge efforts made by
the commission uh the Council made an
important steps with the migration pact
a few hours ago this a good signal this
very positive but we know that it's also
important to work actively on the
external dimension of migration what we
are doing and that's why I believe it's
very important to uh to make sure that
we are more efficient in our fight
against the criminal groups Tak the
against the against the criminal groups
against the the Smugglers we need more
cooperation in the field of policing in
the field of Justice on that question
for two we need to engage with third
countries what we are doing with some
third countries including with Tunisia
we need to cooperate more with those
countries of Origins those countries of
transit in order to protect our borders
in order also to identify some legal
channels of communication and on the
other hand we need to improve the the
returns for those who are not allowed to
stay on the on the European soul and I
would like to confirm that the next
European council meeting will have again
the occasion to address this topic of
migration finally final point I'd like
to thank each and every one of you these
were 48 Hours of intense politics
important for the European Union I think
this meeting has now uh helped very
informal contacts being uh EST
established and we hope that this will
lead to resolution of uh Regional
conflicts Serbia Kosovo uh and we can
understand better what we need to do in
the months to come and the same goes for
the South caucuses as well so this
political platform has shown that it is
important for us to engage the EU should
engaged with other
leaders uh in countries um uh that are
also European
and I think this meeting gives us the
starting point for our discussion on the
Strategic agenda which is going to
continue under the Belgian presidency
and which will set the guidelines so
thank you very much once again dear
Pedro for uh your involvement uh and
your contribution now the president of
the European commission oeline has the
floor first of all I want to thank prime
minister Sanchez de Pedro for the
outstanding uh host you and your country
are for us um to bring us to this
amazing place what an experience
yesterday you hosted the EPC and today
the informal European Council many many
thanks for the very warm welcome today's
informal Summit was about preparing for
the future we met as you know 18 months
ago in versailes right after the
beginning of Russia's invasion in
Ukraine and today it was taking stock
were on what we committed back then a
more secure a more competitive Europe
with stronger defense capabilities
energy Independence and a robust economy
this was the basis for the ver verai
declaration 18 months ago and we
delivered we agreed in record time to
procure and deliver massive financial
and Military Support to Ukraine
team Europe has already provided 82
billion EUR worth of support for
Ukraine we have drastically reduced
Russia's grip on our energy Supply we
got rid of the dependency of Russian fil
fuels just a few figures that show this
we have completely gotten rid of Russian
coal we have reduced the part the part
of Russian oil in the oil Supply from
27% down to
6% and we even had a dependency of 50%
of Russian gas in the overall gas supply
this has been now reduced to less than
10% pipeline gas so this shows that it
was a tough ride it brought us an uh an
energy crisis but we mastered it we
managed it today Energy prices are down
to pre-war levels and most important L
we leaped forward with a massive
investment in renewable energy so that
we can proudly say that last year for
the very first time we were able to
produce more electricity from Sun and
wind Renewables then from gas we also
took a deep and good look at our
economic dependencies you know the
topics critical raw materials or for
example semiconductors here too we
delivered we took action to reduce those
risks think for example um of the chips
act that Trad already massive investment
in production of semiconductors in the
European Union or think about the
critical raw materials act or the Net
Zero industry act this is our proposal
to ensure that the future of clean tech
is in Europe so we've come quite a long
way in only 18 months
but we must keep our eyee on the ball
and he is very helpful Pedro many thanks
for the excellent analysis that was
feeding into our discussion these
analysis points in the same overall
direction of what needs to be
done it goes from protecting and
promoting the increasingly fragile
rules-based International
order to boost research investment and
training in Europe in key sectors and
strengthening social cohesion in the
context of a profound and Rapid
change to these core elements I was just
describing we need to add two more the
first is the crucial issue of managing
migration and the second is the
enlargement process to an European Union
of 30 plus
members the accession process to the
European Union Union is a merits based
one this was very clear also today in
our discussion no shortcuts no automated
accession to the European Union it's
merits based but when we say merits
based we also have to do not only um
work for the merits based process in the
candidate countries but we also have to
do our own homework so that we are ready
in case that countries are candidate
countries are ready to join that we are
also ready to um welcome them to the
European Union we will have the
commission's report the annual report on
the accession and where the state of
play is for the different candidate
countries by beginning of November this
will allow us then to take stock and
have an informed debate during the
December European
Council on our side on tasks we also um
disc discussed is first of all we need
an agreement on the reform of the
electricity Market this is very
important let's keep in mind this is
about Europe's leadership role in the
fight in fighting climate change and
it's about overall EU
competitiveness compared to our main
competitors and I'm not speaking about
competition within the European Union
but competitors from outside and second
we need an agreement on the reform of
the economic governance framework this
is essential to allow public investment
to play a strong and sustainable role in
financing the green and the digital
transition my last point is on
migration first of all good news good
news that two days ago we found an
agreement in Council congratulation to
the Spanish presidency on the crisis
management proposal this is very
important because this is a crucial
piece of the puzzle for the overall
migration and Asylum pact so that now we
hope that soon we will bring it over the
finish line but we have discussed today
mainly the operational part of managing
migration here you know there is the
10-point plan short-time crisis reaction
to the events in lampedusa but also the
more structural mid and long-term
approach like uh the agreement the mou
with
Tunisia let me briefly mention four five
elements that have been discussed the
first is indeed an overall understanding
that we need a comprehensive approach to
partner countries that are either
countries of origin or Transit countries
here is very important that we invest in
those countries global gateway can play
a crucial role with that investment as
you might recall 150 billion EUR of
global gateway are reserved for African
countries for investment in
infrastructure the second is there was
an overall understanding also how
important legal Pathways and
humanitarian corridors are the better we
are on the legal Pathways and the
humanitarian corridors the more we can
be strict on irregular migration just to
give you two figures we had last last
year 3.7 million regular migrants to the
European Union they are important we
need them we need even more but there
were also registered 330,000 irregular
migrants and this is the point where we
cannot accept that Smugglers and
traffickers Define who and decide who is
coming to the European Union it is us
who decide who is coming to the European
Union who get gets Asylum here but also
who has access to the labor market um
and therefore very clearly these legal
Pathways the third point is cracking
down on Smugglers this is organized
crime and we have to fight the smuggling
like organized crime with europ pole and
eurojust and frontex and all the
knowledge of Our member
states the fourth point is support the
countries of Transit who
themselves um have to work hard with the
migration into their countries and here
to work very closely together with ium
and
unhcr to help those countries to bring
migrants back to their uh countries of
origin so to give relief also to the
countries of Transit and the fifth point
is indeed
return we've seen in lampedusa that the
countries of origin for example are
Ivory Coast Sagal Ora Vice pres
president skas went immediately to those
countries to agree that there is a swift
Return of the irregular migrants as I
said in Return to establish Talent
Partnerships and legal Pathways this is
very important to return irregular
migrants to break The Narrative of the
Smugglers and to send out a strong me
message it is the legal Pathways that
will bring you to Europe choose them
this whole um approach is an approach
based on team Europe very clear is also
that none of us is able to do it on our
own so it was a fruitful discussion
among the team Europe thank you thank
you president V deline now I give the
floor to the prime minister of Spain
Sanchez and the host of this
event thank you so much and thank you
Ursula president of the commission thank
you CH
Charles president of the European
Council i' like to begin with thanks
thanks uh to the Spanish government team
they've been working for a year to make
this informal Summit happen and be a
success and I think you've heard from U
the president of the council and the
commission that it has been a success
logistically speaking of course uh uh
but it's uh does demonstrate that uh
when we really have to welcome a major
event such as this in Spain we Spanish
can do it
so congratulations to the whole team
also congratulations to all delegations
all the Personnel the staff of the
council and the commission the
delegations of the 27 member states
because thanks to them it's been a
success and finally thank you to the
municipality of uh Granada the uh
Regional government of Andalusia who
made it possible to uh and the law
enforcement as well who've made it
possible for us to move with relative
ease and uh it's uh been quite a
challenge over the last two days uh but
it's been worth it because I think that
uh this uh city of Granada will now be
linked forever to important declarations
uh you've heard from the president of
the council and the president of the
commission we have been uh we have now
initiated uh the discussion on the next
strategic agenda so what will Europe
like in future how many countries will
be members how will the Union function
how will it take decisions how will it
make sure it remains effective uh in the
face of the challenges and the needs of
our citizens and how are we going to
make our economies more resilient and
more competitive at the end of the day
how are we going to guarantee prosperity
for All European citizens so it's been
worth it Granada will now forever be
linked with a demonstration of political
will shown by the member states to take
forward the European project now
secondly uh the it's the role of the
country holding the presidency to help
to help the president of the council and
the president of the commission to do
their job so over a six Monon period um
and of course at this point in time just
a year away from European elections uh
so we've heard uh just now uh from about
economic governance about uh reforms of
of the electricity Market uh the uh
migration and Asylum PCT those are the
challenges uh and we are committed uh to
uh dealing tackling those we've
demonstrated that over the last period
uh we have achieved an agreement on the
crisis management proposal which is a
key component of the migration and
Asylum pack this is very important
because we now have moving into the
trialogue with the parliament uh with a
View to a final agreement which will
Define for all member states what
responsibilities we have and what
solidarity we want to
demonstrate migration of course being a
major challenge for for the EU as a
whole as to the Strategic agenda you've
just heard from president Michelle and
president F Deion that what we have done
is contribute an important uh report uh
or study which was commissioned a year
ago and has seen contributions of course
from the EU institutions and the member
states but we've what what we've tried
to do is find a landing Zone uh in terms
of what we can agree are is the
Strategic agenda in various policies
whether it's digitalization energy
sovereignty uh The primary
sector agriculture Etc so what does open
strategic autonomy mean uh where are our
strengths where are our weaknesses how
are we vulnerable and how can we become
more resilient and competitive as a
continent as to
enlargement now I'd like to say I'm very
grateful for all the work being done by
VAR think tanks and I'm grateful for the
debate we held today we have to respond
as a union on three fronts so once we
take a political decision uh to go ahead
with the enormous challenge that is
enlargement so we have to then adapt EU
policies and uh I'm thinking here of the
cohesion funds the capap the common
agricultural policy uh anything to do
with the freedom of movement uh citizens
uh what would that look like in a in a
union of 30 members then there is the
question of institutional reform and
finally what sort of enlargement do we
want
gradual or full All or Nothing
so the government of Spain has tried to
do its best make its contribution I hope
presidents uh Michelle and ferine that
we've managed to do that uh and let me
say let me come full circle and say I
want to thank from the bottom of my
heart the people of Granada the uh
collaboration with the regional
government of Andalusia and the
municipality of Granada has been
excellent and our thanks are due to all
the technical teams the sound
technicians uh uh all of the people
working here in the um this uh building
have enabled us to work effectively have
uh made it possible for this uh Summit
to be such a success thank you all once
again so we're here now to answer your
questions the floor now to questions
we'll take four questions one per
journalist um and uh we will start with
B maybe first a question for both
presidents of the council and the
commission um and then one for the prime
minister of Spain so um in spite of all
the um congratulations and comments
about the good news about the agreement
on the on the migration pact um this
Summit has been dominated by a very wild
rhetoric about Migration by some EU
leaders what does it say about the
ownership of the measures that are being
discussed and agreed are you confident
that the situation from 20 5 will not
repeat itself and Europe will still find
themselves in a few years with the same
lack of um yeah putting to force of all
these measures and actually um we are
going into an enlargement and
enlargement and migration are closely
closely linked because of the free
movement of people how how do you intend
to um to go forward that
way and then a question for president
Sanchez
this was a European
first because like other European
countries uh Spain is committed to
enlargement towards the EAS but uh uh
have you started talking about figures
the economic repercussions that this is
going to have for member states from the
point of view of uh agricultural uh
subsidies how uh is Spain going to
contribute to uh this enlargement
process if you don't know what the uh uh
um
enlargement and also I'd like to know
what kind of assessment do you have
about what will have uh on the uh
formation of a government front here in
Spain there are two elements that I need
to look at on migration there's nothing
new here all the debates over the last
years have been ideological difficult
often emotional but there have always
been uh two aspects there's this
solidarity between European countries we
need to make progress and I think a
substantial step forward has been taken
under Spanish presidency uh and the
migration pact agreement has also helped
and uh sometimes uh uh it was very
difficult to move forward because we had
contrasting uh positions and we need to
work now uh to implement this pact in a
fair way this is shared responsibility
ities that's the first element the
second
element I think we need to be
pragmatic on the external
Dimension we see a broad consensus in
the European Council that we need to act
on the external Dimension as a priority
let me give you some examples firstly we
need to better protect the Union's
external borders provide our support to
countries uh uh that will help us
protect our borders we need to be more
active more operational to demonstrate
to the criminals that they abuse the
distress and the vulnerability of people
who imperil their lives we need to uh
show them uh that uh uh they will not
win so we need more cooperation
intergovernmental cooperation and we
need also greater involvement of justice
and law enforcement to combat these
criminals to make it clear that they
cannot uh uh continue this way and
thirdly we need to engage with the
countries of origin and
Transit we need a global a holistic
approach I know it's not simple we need
a lot of debate negotiation we've talked
a lot about the new memorandum of
understanding with Tunisia uh and this
is a commitment that we need to enter it
into let me just give you two examples
we will show to what extent we need uh
to have a very sensitive approach to all
of this uh
are countries of Transit uh and we all
to need to talk about liberalized
visas uh and let's I forget that there
some countries of uh uh country have
liberalized Visa policies with other
countries T Tunisia has for example with
Western uh African countries so some
people from uh western African countries
can arrive uh easily to Tunisia and then
move on so we need to discuss all of
this these people it's a matter of
Mobility also we need to open legal
channels of migration uh we need to we
need to be the ones who decide who will
have legal access to European territory
and another point is that we need to
make sure that our return policy becomes
more effective we see uh all too often
that return and readmission do not work
properly so these are the sorts of
issues that we're going to continue
working on we're going to continue being
committed to and that's an approach that
we're going to continue and then briefly
on enlargement well yes we are
absolutely determined to put this point
high up on our agenda it's not going to
be simple we uh we're going to have to
reform uh uh our institutions uh we also
need reform of the countries that want
to exceed so we all see eye to eye this
is a a process that has to be Merit
based we need to be frank uh but we also
need to uh uh see exactly what the uh uh
repercussions are going to be on the EU
from the point of view of priorities
financing Etc so we're going to have
fairly tough debates ahead of us and we
will see in the months to come that we
are going to be having these debates but
we need to set our sides for the years
to come I am confident that we will find
good Solutions what migration is
concerned with migration is
important that we manage it migration
was always there will always be there
the question is how we are managing it
as team Europe and there are two
Dimension the one is the internal
Dimension this is covered by The Pact of
migration and
Asylum and we could speak a lot about it
but it is on its way now in the
negotiations between um Parliament and
Council and there's a um very good
chance that it will make it over the
Finish Line this is very important to to
manage Migra migration on the borders of
the European Union and within the
European Union but as important as this
internal Dimension is the external
Dimension the external action there was
a broad support today in the European
Council for this external Dimension and
I have described in my introductory
remarks the different steps concerning
that the principle is that you address
the root causes for migration and that
you work along the whole migratory route
the people take and the basic message is
yes we need regular migration we want
regular migration and we do not want
people to risk their lives and lose a
fortune or what they ever have as
financial means to the Smugglers and
traffickers but that they choose the
safe Pathways and here the work as team
Europe is extremely important because
this includes comprehensive Partnerships
with the countries of origin and the
countries of Transit and we have much
more leverage and much better results
for these comprehensive approaches if we
work as team Europe what enlargement is
concerned there will be on one hand the
report on the progress of the different
countries
this is crucial because there we can
then uh with facts and figures take
stock how the progress were where was
and where they stand but of course in
parallel the discussion about what does
it mean for us how do we have to change
and adapt and prepare for the future as
a European Union will go on um many
thanks uh prime minister what you said
about the work that is being done in
think tanks but also during your
presidency this will certainly continue
during the Belgium presidency too and
the commission is working on different
policy areas to give food for thought
into this process on how we can improve
the situation within the Lisbon
treaty thank you for your questions just
briefly in response to the first and
second yesterday we met uh in the
European political community and I met
up with seninsky privately and he asked
me he said in Spain well is there or
isn't there support for
Ukraine and defending Ukraine in other
words uh against Russian aggression I
said there was a broad majority to
support Ukraine now if anyone uh studies
the political debate in our country I
think it's clear that broadly speaking
we are in favor and we support Ukraine
we think this is a just cause they're
defending their Nation their territorial
integrity and their
freedom so if that's the the support of
Spanish Society for Ukraine uh because
in the face of this unjustified
aggression it's also clear that
uh Spanish society and the Spanish
government are in
favor of uh also beginning
these uh negotiations with Ukraine on
its possible accession Spain joined what
was then the European economic community
in the 80s of the previous uh Century so
why on Earth would we object to other
countries who have been waiting at the
door for so long being integrated into
the union of course we would like to see
extension of the Union into areas which
in geopolitical terms are also very
important uh I'm thinking here of the
western Balkans of course
so we are societ and governments that
are open to enlargement but of course
from there to making it happen we have
to answer difficult complex questions we
have to demonstrate political will as
you've said what will happen with uh the
various funds there will of course be
issues of foreign policy of uh fiscal
policy to be dealt with um but uh We've
begun the process we've launched the
debate it's very important politically
speaking we have formally launched the
debate what it's part of what we call
the Strategic agenda and we are now uh
committed to a process in which in the
next presidency under Belgian presidency
the agenda will be fixed and we will
continue working toward the future we'll
see how we'll see what the details are
and what reforms and adaptations are
necessary but uh in Spain we have always
been constructive in our approach to
proposals we've always contributed and
uh uh talking about
sumar the political party um yes we uh
note their uh proposal we also note the
proposals of other political parties on
the amnesty which is one way of of
overcoming the uh
judicial impact uh of uh various uh
decisions and what as a consequence of
what happened in 2017 so there are
proposals but of course they are not
proposals of the Socialist
Party I've also said that uh having
received uh uh the
uh request of the king to attend attempt
to form a government I will uh engage in
that process establish what the
positions are on all sides and all
parties uh should try to work towards uh
Set uh making a government possible as
soon as possible now I know there are
questions you want to ask or what would
the contents of such an agreement be to
form a government well I can't tell you
until we've got the agreement because
we're in the midst of the of the
negotiations but what I can say to the
Spanish people is that it will be an
agreement when it comes full in full
transparency it will be made fully
public secondly the objective is clear
and simple we want to continue doing
what we've been doing for five years
Progressive policies and policies of uh
working together within the confines of
the Spanish Constitution so you will be
the first to know when the negotiations
are concluded and of course there will
be no agreement until everything is
agreed nothing is agreed until
everything is agreed that's all I mean
it
makes sense and applies in all areas of
life and politics too to stick to one
question for journalist Jose
Miguel good afternoon I'd like to ask
you about migration uh was prime
minister Orban W very tough on the uh
migration and Asylum pact CU he said
that this violates his country uh did
for Poland uh was there any compromise
do you think that there's any alignment
possible or do you just rule it out and
are you not afraid that this matter is
going to monopolize the whole discussion
around the European elections next
year and for the president of the uh
government a couple of
questions you haven't been able to come
up with a a joint
declaration uh and migration could not
be included in the joint Declaration of
the summit and then as regards
uh your uh government you said that
you're going to be uh perhaps meeting
with Mr P deont but would it be possible
uh that there might be a meeting with uh
sorry you won't be meeting Mr push but
you might be meeting a member of his
party see
well yes on the first question can I say
there is a joint declaration what there
isn't is uh uh a paragraph on migration
and this was an informal Council this is
an informal Council what do I mean by
this the most important is that we have
uh uh managed to uh uh endorse what our
home Affairs ministers managed to agree
on a couple of weeks ago go and this is
absolutely important cuz now we can
unblock the situation this is what the
European Parliament asked us to do we
can then uh finish off the trialogues
that we began under the Czech and then
Swedish presidencies and we can now
reach an agreement on this crisis
regulation so from this point of
view well I mean we knew that there was
a risk there the president of the
council and I myself as well as the
president of uh the Italian government
did ask us to put this point on the
agenda today the point of migration but
let's not forget Granada was convened to
talk about the Strategic ad agenda to
talk about enlargement to talk about
resilience and competitiveness of the
European economy now on your second
question look we're in the negotiation
process and nothing is agreed until
everything is agreed let me insist uh
the uh Spaniards voted on the 23rd of
July they spoke and this is what the uh
result is up to us now to form a
government for the next four years so we
need to talk about all of this I mean
are we
negotiating for me taking uh over but I
don't know but U I'm still negotiating
with the Parliamentary group so that
somebody becomes prime minister uh and
uh takes up on uh follows the will of
the Spanish people I mean we we need to
continue with the same policies make
progress social progress and able to
live together I think uh we all know uh
that the situation in Catalonia is much
better than in
2017 uh and obviously we have to work
within the framework of the Spanish
Constitution and we are going to reach
an agreement and as soon as we have we
will be transparent AR in public about
this
and I mean if somebody wants to uh if
the opposition wants to have recourse to
the Constitutional Court then they're
quite happy to do so this is a democracy
Spanish democracy is working to uh
uh implement the Mandate that they gave
us last
July just briefly on migration as the
Spanish prime minister he said there is
a Grenada Declaration on the Strategic
agenda and separately uh the president
of the European Council is has issued a
declaration with broad support uh uh on
migration you've had an opportunity to
see that text uh as I said it's broadly
supported and contains what uh uh was
contributed by myself and the uh
Commission on the external dimension of
migration we'll go to the we will go to
the third question Carl
uh for the
French about enlargement uh for you
president Michelle new figures have uh
emerged this week about the amount of uh
cohesion and agricultural funds that
Ukraine and other candidate countries
could benefit from uh after accession
can you please give us uh some details
about the methodology of your uh
services on which figures of GDP
population they they are based
and for uh both of you president fan and
president Misha what conclusions do you
draw from these uh figures what does it
mean about these two policies
Agriculture and cohesion uh does it mean
that um we have to reduce the share of
these policies in the total budget or
that we must increase the EU budget Way
Beyond the 1% of GDP that is uh already
uh today in
place
yes I think the answer to your question
uh is in my the introduction I made
earlier this is a political and
democratic debate which uh was launched
today has to do with the priorities for
tomorrow in the and with enlargement in
view but we also need to look at the
financial uh framework now I'm not going
to comment on leaks to the Press there
is Technical and serious work underway
that will be pursued with the member
states the commission will contribute so
that we can uh look at what the treaties
call the absorption capacity in their
rather bureaucratic uh terms and we will
see of course um
how that can work we've identified here
in Granada what the Strategic framework
is for this debate for that discussion
we have identified what the key
objectives are which are largely shared
we want uh Europe to be less dependent
less vulnerable more able to defend its
values and defend its interests those
are the key points uh We've identified
sectors where we have to work harder and
we've identified the fact that uh the
financial means for all this is a
crucial matter now when we debated the
rrf we spent four days and four nights
negotiating as you will recall and we
I'm convinced that we'll have to come
back to all of that it will be a complex
negotiation but it's absolutely
necessary because we need a budget that
is aligned with the priorities and the
Ambitions it's about being consistent
with putting our money where our mouth
is
effectively as far as I understand um
this is a council paper and I cannot
comment on that one indeed uh we have
been asked today during the European
Council to contribute to the estimate
that can be done important is here I
think that we keep in mind that we
cannot just extrap poite policies of
today over the next decade this is
impossible because we all know also the
policies a decade ago changed over time
I like the surrounding environment is
changing so we have to work on different
scenarios and we will um work on figures
that might be uh playing into a full
picture
uh about the development but let me in
principle say the we have a lot of
experience with accession and
enlargement and the experience has shown
in every case that it was not only
beneficial to the country that joined
the European Union but that the
accession was also beneficial to the
European Union to a wide extent and um
this is true because mainly we the
strongest element we we have in our
Union besides the rule of law in which
our Union is founded is our single
Market the biggest single Market in the
world and indeed an enlargement also
means if the countries are ready and the
preconditions are good to join it always
means that it is an improvement for our
companies with access to more consumers
and it's Improvement for our people with
access to better and more Goods so the
experience has shown that Not only was
the living standard of the accessing
countries Rising but the whole of the
European Union has benefited a lot again
I
say the accessing countries have to be
ready and we have to be ready this is a
precondition for
success thank you very much and the
fourth question we'll take Andrew from
Reuters thank you Andrew Gray from
Reuters uh president Michelle the
Granada declaration does not include the
date of 2030 which you've proposed as as
a Target date for the EU being ready for
enlargement does that mean that date is
now off the table or can you give us a
sense of how the leaders have reflected
on that proposal so far and the same or
similar question to president verion and
prime minister Sanchez do you believe
2030 is a helpful and realistic uh
potential Target date thank
you well this date isn't in the
Declaration but it never
was uh so I suggested that we put in the
data uh
before first and foremost we need to
look at real progress made by the
countries now if they are ambitious and
if they want to be ready then they can
be by 2030 certainly uh it's useful uh
but some heads of government and state
did actually Express reservations about
how having a date others liked a date
but what's important is to see what our
responsibility is we the 27 to put our
house in order to prepare ourselves for
uh accession as well as see what they
need to do so that they are ready but we
have to stop procrastinating that's
important especially in the current uh
situation of the war in Ukraine we need
to turn to those who want to join us to
say we are
serious so
we I think uh we have to put an end to
their feeling of uh being uh ignored and
uh forgotten over nearly 20 years in the
Balkans so that's the idea I think uh
this discussion that we've had I think
shows how uh how the European debate is
Lively I think if it's a project uh if
progress is made then setting a date
actually is an encouragement it it it
encourages them to work to reform and to
be ready and I think it's of geograph
geopolitical importance for Europe so
the idea isn't to be a bigger uh and
more populous in Europe but more uh
robust uh more prosperous safer more
stable for the future so enlargement I
think means that we will build a Europe
that is more stable and secure for the
future so I think I have said uh several
times already um how the process is the
process is merits
based it is no
automatism and not one size fits all but
it is individual there are clear rules
there are Milestones that have to be
achieved there are the Copenhagen
criteria which describe what the goal is
in the past we have of course also seen
that countries that wanted to join the
European Union somewhere fast depending
on the political will to reform and some
took more time and some so far never
made it therefore it is a merits based
process yes what the commission
president uh has said is that of course
at the end of the day it's a process of
negotiation with those uh
other applicant countries and I have
nothing to add but uh in 2030 of course
uh together with uh Morocco Spain will
be hosting uh the World Cup so another
reason to celebrate in
[Music]